vendre des canaux on fait ça depuis 113
ans dans la famille de jean légaré une
pandémie chez parlophone mais ça leur a
permis de mettre de l'argent dans le
plein air 2020 a été une année record
le même scénario se dessine pour 2021 on
a presque vendu l'équivalent de l'année
dernière des jo puis on est au début
mais que ce soit le kayak le canot ou la
plancha pagaie tout part à la vitesse
grand v
ça a été un peu l'explosion autant dans
les ventes que dans les centres de
location que sur les lieux de pratique
une popularité propulsé par la pandémie
les sportifs sont contraints de rester
au pays la masse qui arrive subitement
sur le plan d'eau où on n'a souvent pas
peut-être pas les infrastructures pour
répondre à cette arrivée massive là ce
qui provoque une cohabitation plus
difficile avec les résidents quand on a
préparé une activité on se rend compte
qu'il ya des autos partout puis qu'on
veut quand même y aller il arrivait
souvent des comportements qui sont pas
du tout adéquat le des endroits qui sont
stationnent déjà qu'ils sont stationnés
dans des parcs du qui bloquent les
entrées des gens dit citoyenne et
plusieurs de ses nouveaux adeptes sont
des néophytes conditions météo 20 le
cours est la température de l'eau net au
printemps faut pas sous-estimer la
température de l'eau une méconnaissance
qui a coûté cher en vies humaines
l'un dernier on avait 95 décès liés à
l'eau c'est 15 de plus que la moyenne de
80 qu'on a au cours des deux dernières
années selon un rapport de la division
québécoise la société de sauvetage
84 % des noyades ont eu lieu sur un plan
d'eau naturel il ya plus d'un an
moyennant rivières au québec que partout
ailleurs dans le reste du canada
dans le reste du canada c'est plutôt le
contraire c'est les lacs et la moitié
d'entre elles impliquaient des
embarcations nautiques
neuf fois sur dix ils ne portaient pas
ou ne portait pas correctement leur
verre flotté des morts qu une simple
veste aurait pu éviter
selon la société de sauvetage ici marie
josée paquet comme radio canada montréal